I remember when I had a deal but it was
all for a five thousand pounds
I offered 62 and a half always to be
specific in your offer why is it makes
it a way you thought about it
TV's over a 509 465 they'll say meet me
in the middle of 75 if you something at
85 and offer 62 and a half they'll go
round up to 63 it's just a psychology of
putting in an offer
I offered 62 and a half and they said
around 63
I'm like yes now this time on 19 years
old 17 years old bought one house 18
years old abort 0 houses just at a very
very long year of work experience and
trying and failing 19 years old I've now
put this off on it to be accepted
problem is I've got no money so they
said Samuel congratulations your offers
accepted all you need to send us now
he'll cruise off a dress I'm not easy
soliciting these house isn't mortgage
broker details easily photo ID easy a
proof of the pass there
Oh like I'm gonna really boil it I don't
really any money though I did have one
spent on training then my drama student
is telling me that I'm an idiot but I
got no money some well the offers
accepted run away and then they write me
the next day saying we need to see you
proof a deposit otherwise we can't take
the house off the market
I'm like what do you actually need for
me then they said we just need a
screenshot of your name on your bank and
the money in your account and the
deposit is a thirteen thousand pound
that we need to see that so right off my
brother I said what sausage F 13 grand
he said no he's two and a half years
older I said well how much do you have
he's like ten thousand as a German
overdraft he said yes I said how much
for he said 3000 I said perfect
I said can you please send me away all
your money plus all your overdraft
because I'm buying this house
he was like yeah no I was like man I'm
buying this house he's a really good
deal maybe we could do it to eventually
he says no dude
I need that ten thousand four bills and
stuff and Rutger and maxing out my over
just not afford to eat and at this boy
was so scared that I was literally
having to suppose like I'll break down
because they left petrol it was skinny's
I had a HMO and a house it was a free
house because I bought it creative
Elena's giving me about nine ten hundred
pounds a month profit which is great but
I'm using that to live off some skit no
other income stream and I'm driving a
lot of couldn't paint for Network
meetings and training in this and that
yeah a lot a skint I said what I need
this house I said give me thirteen
thousand pounds and I'll give it to you
back in three minutes
he was like what I said bro I said do
you trust me he said yes I said do you
love me
said yeah I said just send me the 13
quite not send me back in three minutes
he's a how is that gonna help you though
I said just do it he said six to me
however I see him a banking a lot that
looks nice
I gotta said I've got two more minutes
of this so what the dough I just
screenshots it I sent it back they know
it's the agents with the screenshot the
next day the mother I'm not suggesting
that you do this I'm just telling you my
story
that's not very ethical listen man so
Moses want to bleed just have to do
whatever it freaking takes you know and
I'll just needs to get this house off
the market knowing this how long does it
take for a house to complete two or
three months and now that two or three
months to actually get the money but the
house is gonna be off the market again
always no I'm not suggesting you do this
I just tell you my story so they say
that looks good
they took the house off the market and I
got two or three months now I'm going to
every single property networking event I
possibly can trying to beg to get money
I'm like hey I've got a contract set
I'll give you 10% return on investment
for five years I've got it already and
I'm trying to get this money and
everyone say no and I'm going around
like a beggar and I'm going to these
networking events that I'm so desperate
it's like honestly I just walk into a
room and it's as if you can see
desperate written on my forehead you
know desperate broke need your help and
instead of me kind of focusing on what
I've got going for me I was just focused
on why I didn't have which is the money
alone so obviously I never money I got
no money
I need money can you give me some money
I've got this great deal right on and
I'm focusing on the lack rather than
focusing what I had and what you focus
on tends to expand so if you focus on
what you don't have that actually expand
to see when you focus on what you do
about that expense so let's load on the
wrong problem is a resort that two and a
half months our gets though call off the
stage insane Samuel I think with you to
complete your service purchase Lister
I'm my sister my sister said we're
completely in four days time and you got
the monies home really now not only am I
gonna lose the deal but I'm also going
to lose my relationship with the
solicitor who's
friend and I'm gonna kill the
relationship with the agent it's gonna
be embarrassing I'm stressed I'm
desperate to get their money I go to a
networking event I've got the contracts
written up I'm dead but can't happen
Monday they said that the deals gone
we're gonna put the property back on the
market
I've got till Monday morning it's now
Saturday sad I know I go to a property
networking event stand up and I'm like
trying to pitch I don't just like being
treated like a leper go outside I know
and I thought I'm giving up man I've
been doing this for two years I've got
one property but for the last 12 months
I've not bought anything and don't I
went to my grandma's house the next day
for a Sunday roast
I was like just forget it girls in the
mood she's almost up I said oh she's
also and I told her I just said I've got
this house the problem I'll start
telling this story and she's our sister
changes if I would know any festive you
doing I said because I don't know why
the deals bright I was getting given 10
she's I've attempted it's really good
I'm really sorry though she's 10 percent
I'm surprised like that's the lot bed in
the bank I'm like no she said well what
would happen if you couldn't pay the
investor back though I'm like well I
could if I could oh if the house doesn't
right now it's on my head I'll make it
happen
I've got this other property I've got
everything that the property Jesus yeah
but what about this what about this none
so we're like is she interested she says
look at the contract I'm like oh my
goodness my grandma is interested so
we're looking at the contracts am I
talking about it for maybe from a third
party what the university might think
point of view but now it's kind of get
situation where we're talking about the
deal as if the investor but I know and
she knows that I know that she knows
that we're talking about her as this
conversation goes on a little bit we
stop talking she goes well she looks
over at my granddad mcwendell looks over
her Miranda gives a little nod
she says we got some savings and could
be interested well yeah yeah she says
when would you need the money boy I'm
thinking like tomorrow morning ideally
tomorrow but like obviously no pressure
she was well we'll never know think
about it and maybe we'll talk to you in
the next few days or I can't push this
grandma and I just I just like or we
drop it I go home I go to bed I wake up
in the morning I wake up at 7:01 I look
at more open Facebook I've got a
Facebook message for my grandma at 6:54
a.m. she says Samuel we've gone through
everything I've spoken to you granddad
where do you need the money so Ned like
I was like I was like Grandma
I said that's amazing thank you and I
sent her the details she's every 15,000
pounds 13 for the deposit in 2004 the
legals and stuff I bought the house are
we completed within a few weeks I bought
the house 63,000 it's now over 130,000
it's it was renting out giving me about
24 percent return on investment what
while I do is the 15 grand that will
grandma gave me every year in August I'd
give her 1500 pound interesting 1,500
1,500 thank you thank you
yeah 1500 we never spoke about the money
continue having a good relationship it
was just looking be able to do thing we
didn't talk about it and let like even
my dad Lou is my dad's mom I'm a dad by
the way fell out with me when I left the
family business so like it was all a bit
kind of awkward and the dad was like you
want to do what probably investing you
know I've really call it no call my
father I'm a dad now he's one of my
tenants but anyway so I'm sending above
ground for all this 1500 and then after
four and a half years I'm thinking I
need to give the money back to my
grandma now as it happens for know
obviously I'm quite a while
they got lots of properties I got lots
of equity so I can easily give him all
the money back so I further up I said
grandma it's been four and a half years
I've been giving you 10% interest every
August and I said but this August I need
to give you 10% into s plus you 15 come
back so how do you want me to pack and
she said yeah actually I want to talk to
you about that about that money that we
gave you was like isn't that okay oh
well mainly plan that have been talking
a lot on we'd like to see you in person
now I'm thinking oh my goodness she's
probably been on Zoopla and seen how
much the house is worth now he's gone
hello and I was a she put all the money
in but I've been getting probably more
profit from her then she's been again
and I've got the equity equity and the
cabins depreciation the house I think
she's pissed but we had a contract it
was all really clear of I'd done what I
said I'll see her there and she been
getting a lot more than she would at the
banking of course so I saw around the
house and I'm like well what's up she's
doing it to conversate you know look
did you do any like tomorrow if you want
I'll give you everything backing you
know like don't know as it's only well
we wanted to talk to you because there
is a thing we get when we gave you that
money that 15,000 pound you know was sat
in that bank before and it was given us
a smaller interest but here's the thing
Samuel we've only got so much money you
know and we have you 15 grand and we've
been using the interest that you've been
giving us to go on an annual cruise and
it's first it's like a free cruise and
we just wondered if we could extend the
contract one more year so we can have
one more free cruise
I'm like Burma I thought you were upset
with me she was like upset you crazy
baby now see God I was like oh I'm like
no but we can extend it of course we can
extend it for it earlier
guess what following year comes up she
has to extend it one more year
guess what I'm not 28 years old on 2900
couple months my net worth is 16 million
pounds my grandma's still what let me
give you that big thing on that
[Applause]
[Music]